Mein Name ist Ucak, ich bin aus dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Dr.
Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Ich werde Ihnen gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen, bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, gerne.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Max Heydrich.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Namen langsam beschreiben?
M-A-X, Martha Anton X.
Mein Name ist H-I-D-R-I-S-H.
Okay. Herr Heydrich, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
2.3.1993
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 75 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 85.
Okay. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Frau Schmidt.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen.
Herr Heydrich, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe seit zwei Tagen Schwindelig.
Okay. Herr Heydrich, haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Ja, Doktor. Ich hatte zwei Monate Schwindelig.
Ich erinnere mich jetzt.
Und waren Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden bei anderen Arzten gewesen?
Nein. Ich denke, das ist nicht plötzlich oder wichtig.
Aber ich habe jetzt ähnliche Beschwerden wieder.
Ich habe bei ihnen gegangen.
Okay. Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen, Herr Heydrich.
Danke schön.
Herr Heydrich, darf ich fragen, sind diese Schwindelig plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Es kam plötzlich aufgetreten, Doktor.
Und gibt es einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schwindel? Haben Sie bemerkt?
Bestimmter Auslöser? Nein. Ohne einen bestimmten Auslöser. Nein.
Und gibt es etwas, das den Schwindel verschlimmert oder lindert?
Verschlimmert, ja.
Gibt es etwas, das diesen Schwindel verschlimmert oder eine Position, zum Beispiel legen oder stehen?
Ja. Das Licht ist mir zu hell, Doktor. Ich halte das kaum aus.
Verstehen Sie? Ja, also Sie haben Lichtempfindlichkeit, richtig? Ja, richtig.
Okay. Außerdem halte ich über, Doktor.
Und mussten Sie erbrechen? Ja, ja.
Wie viel haben Sie erbrochen?
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich fünf oder sechsmal erbrochen, ja.
Okay. Wie sah das Erbrochen aus? Ich meine, haben Sie Blut bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht Blut bemerkt.
Okay. Herr Heydrich, haben Sie gegen diese Beschwerden ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe eine Tablette Dolalmin genommen, aber das hat leider nicht geholfen.
Alles klar. Leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ja, ja. Richtig. Sie haben Recht.
Außerdem habe ich Kopfschmerzen, so ein Tumfenschmerz auf der rechten Seite, ja.
Darf ich fragen, seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Schwindelig, oder?
Kopfschmerzen. Ah, Kopfschmerzen. Seit zwei Tagen, Doktor.
Ähnlich, ja? Ja, ja.
Außerdem kann ich auch nicht gut schlafen und ich habe keinen Apathet seit zwei Tagen, ja Doktor.
Ich denke, wegen dieser Beschwerden schlafe ich nicht gut, ich denke.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Beide, ich denke.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Heydrich, also leiden Sie unter Sehstörungen oder Hörstörungen?
Ja, ich habe nicht bemerkt. Aber wegen dieser Empfindlichkeit,
beim Gehen schwanke ich und fühle mich sehr unsicher.
Herr Heydrich, darf ich fragen, ist dieses Schwindel wie auf einem Karussell oder auf einem Boot,
ich meine, drehen alles um, oder?
Ja, alles um, ja, alles um, richtig, ja.
Okay, und leiden Sie unter Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribbeln oder Lähmung in Extrapolitik?
Ich meine, Beine oder Arme?
Kribbeln, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor, nein.
Auch Lähmung?
Ja, ich habe keine Lähmung, nein.
Okay, haben Sie eine Nackensteifigkeit bemerkt?
Können Sie wieder...
Haben Sie Nackensteifigkeit bemerkt?
Ja, nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay, Herr Heydrich, darf ich fragen, haben Sie eine komische Geräusche im Ohr bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe einmal bemerkt, ja, ja, ja, richtig, aber einmal.
Aber momentan? Momentan haben Sie nicht, ja?
Ja, momentan nicht, aber gestern kurze Zeit ungefähr 3-2 Minuten, ja, ich habe bemerkt, ja.
Okay, und darf ich fragen, wie lange dauert diese Schwindelattacke?
Ungefähr eine oder zwei Stunden.
Okay, alles klar.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Übelkeit und müssten erbrechen?
Ja, haben Sie Fieber oder Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe das Fieber nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberlich.
Ich habe keine Fieber, ich denke.
Das freut mich.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit am Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stuhlgang.
Leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor.
Alles klar.
Herr Heidlich, sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, Doktor, richtig.
Ich bin vollständig gegen Corona geimpft.
Nein, nicht zweimal, viermal nicht.
Alles klar.
Herr Heidlich, leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen von denen,
denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Milithochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Aber ich habe seit ungefähr drei Jahren Schulteschmerzen.
Da ist, glaube ich, eine Verkalkung drin.
Mein Hausarzt hat auch gesagt, dass ich einen Tennis-Ellenbogen habe.
Ich habe früher Tennis gespielt, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme am Schulter oder am Ellenbogen?
Beide.
Beide, okay.
Nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen eingenommen?
Ja, wenn ich Schmerzen habe, nehme ich bei Bedarf Ibuprofen 500 mg ein, Doktor.
Aber bei Bedarf.
Ich nehme auch zwei Mal pro Woche.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, Doktor, ich war einmal operiert.
Wir wurden vor vier Jahren Mandeln entfernt.
Vor vier Jahren Mandeln entfernt, ja?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich hatte auch mal eine Lungenentzündung, aber das ist schon länger.
Wie wurde diese Lungenentzündung behandelt?
Im Krankenhaus oder mit Antibiotika?
Nein, mein Hausarzt hat mir eine Antibiotika gegeben.
Ich habe eine Woche genutzt. Das war gut.
Alles klar. Okay, und sonst? Haben Sie irgendwelche andere Voroperationen?
Nein, ich habe keine andere Operation.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten noch irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente regelmäßig, aber ich habe gesagt, ich habe Dolamin angenommen und manchmal einen Nasenspray, Sonarin, wenn es nötig ist.
Sonarin, habe ich gesagt, ja?
Ja, ja.
Und wogegen benutzen Sie diesen Spray?
Wogegen benutzen Sie ihn?
Ich habe einen Ritus-Doktor.
Okay, sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ich denke, ich bin allergisch auf dem Halt.
Wenn ich lange Zeit in einem Office bleibe, habe ich Ritus.
Aber ich bin nicht sicher.
Okay, alles klar. Und sonst?
Das war es, oder?
Das war es nicht.
Gehaltlich rauchen Sie?
Ja, Doktor, ich rauche leider.
Seit wann und wie oft? Wie viel?
Seit 10 Jahren rauche ich halb Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Okay. Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich nur am Wochenende.
Meistens 3 bis 4 Gläser Wein zusammen mit meiner Frau.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen, Doktor.
Das freut mich.
Herr Hajdrich, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall?
Schlaganfall, bitte.
Ja, meine Familie gibt es Bluthochdruck.
Meine Mutter hat das und wurde wegen einer Fremdung an der Haschlackada operiert.
Reicht.
Außerdem habe ich meine Mutter an Bluthochdruck.
Mein Vater hat auch Bluthochdruck und hatte vor 3 Jahren einen Schlaganfall.
Okay, alles klar. Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind, Doktor.
Okay. Sie sind verheiratet und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe 2 gesunde Jungs.
Herr Hajdrich, wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ich lebe mit meiner Frau.
Und was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich bin Schwimmemaster.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Hajdrich, ich möchte eine Frage über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden stellen.
Also, haben Sie eine Verletzung gehabt, besonders am Kopf?
Verletzung? Ich erinnere mich.
Jetzt, Doktor, nein.
Okay, alles klar. Das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, ich denke, meine Situation ist sehr schlecht.
Ich kann nicht arbeiten und ich kümmere mich nicht um meine Kinder. Was habe ich?
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Herr Hajdrich.
Also, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus und bei uns in guten Händen.
Es ist zu früh, etwas genau zu sagen.
Ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, dass Sie ein Problem mit den Ohren haben.
Aber wie gesagt, werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen und ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und dann ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Was ist körperliche Untersuchung? Untersuchen Sie mein Ohr, oder?
Ja, ich werde Ihren Ohr untersuchen.
Ich werde den ganzen Körper untersuchen. Das ist sehr wichtig bei uns.
Diese Beschwerden sind gefährlich?
Wie gesagt, es ist zu früh, etwas zu sagen, Herr Hajdrich.
Nach der Untersuchung können wir darüber widersprechen.
Aber wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Wir haben zu viele Erfahrungen mit diesen Situationen.
Und wie gesagt, wir werden alles für Sie tun.
Also ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Ich habe gesagt, mein Vater hatte Schlaganfall.
Ich habe Angst über Schlaganfall.
Es könnte sein, dass ich Schlaganfall werde.
Also Herr Hajdrich, Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sind nicht Schlaganfall.
Ich glaube, Sie haben ein Problem mit Ihren Ohren.
Und auch wir werden Ihr Gehirn untersuchen mit ein paar Bildgebenden.
Danach können wir darüber widersprechen.
Danke schön, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie.
Sehr gerne. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke sehr schön.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Max Hajdrich ist 33 Jahre alt.
75 Kilogramm schwer, 1,85 Meter groß.
Herr Hajdrich stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehender flüssig aufgetretener Vertigo und seit zwei Tagen bestehender rechtsseitiger Dumpfhalcephalgie vor,
den Patienten zufolge habe er ähnliche Beschwerden vor zwei Monaten gehabt.
Er habe keinen Arzt wegen dieser Beschwerden besucht.
Er erwähnte, dass es keine auslöser für diese Beschwerden gibt, aber er berichtete über eine Lichtempfindlichkeit.
Diese Beschwerden seien mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Außerdem berichtete der Patient über Nausea mit fünf- bis sechsmaliger Emesis.
Der Patient habe wegen dieser Beschwerden ein Dolamin-Tablet eingenommen, aber das Tablet hat keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Er berichtete auch um die Sicherheit und die Fragen nach Kopfverletzung, Sehstörungen, Hörstörungen, Hypesthesie, Parasthesie, Parasie, Nackensteifigkeit.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass er gestern einen Tymiditus für drei bis vier Minuten gehabt.
Bei der Vegetative Anamnese seien die Folgen bekannt.
Insomnie, Inapetens, er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und viermal Covid-19 geimpft.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit drei Jahren bestehende Schulterschmerzen und Tendoragenitis im Ellenbogen rechts.
Vor einem Monat, früher diagnostizierte Pneumonie, die mit Antibiotika für eine Woche behandelt wurden,
er nehme Ibuprofen 500 mg bei Bedarf ein bis zwei Mal pro Woche gegen Schulterschmerzen.
Vor vier Jahren sei bei ihm eine Transilektomie durchgeführt worden und er benutze auch eine Nasenspray gegen Renitis.
Er habe Allergie gegen Hausstaub, die sich durch Renitis äußert.
Er sei Raucher und er rauche seit zehn Jahren zehn Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinke drei bis vier Gläser Wein am Wochenende, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater an Arteriella Hypertonii an und er habe vor drei Jahren an Apoplex gelitten.
Die Mutter leide an Arteriella Hypertonii und bei ihr sei eine Karotis-Endarterektomie durchgeführt worden.
Er sei Einzelkind, verheiratet und er habe zwei gesunde Söhne.
Er wohnt mit seiner Frau und er sei Schlimmmeister von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Morbus miliaire aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter Vertigo Cephalgie, einmal Getinitus und diese Beschwerden Nausea und Emesis auch.
Diese Beschwerden sind auch Symptome für eine Morbus miliaire.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen vestibular Neuritis, Gehirntumor oder Gehirnblutung in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich die VITAR-Parameter überwachen und eine körperliche und neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Störungen der Motorik, Sensorik oder andere Funktionen vorliegen.
Ich achte darauf, ob eine Seh- und Hörstörung, Hautfarbeveränderung vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laborkuntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine CT-Deschedels veranlassen, um die möglichen Pathologien wie Blutengern oder Tumore zu beurteilen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten mit einer Tumore,
und würde den Patienten eine Analyngetika, Antiemetika verabreichen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich ein neurologisches Konsil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise verstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, Sie würden die CT-Deschedels durchführen.
Welche Diagnostik-Pathologien müssen Sie ausschließen?
Wir sollen besonders gegen Blut und Tumore ausschließen.
Ich meine, Sie sind nur bei der CT-Deschedels, oder Herr Oberarzt?
Welche Gehirrtümer denken Sie in diesem Fall?
Ich habe keine speziellen Gehirrtümer, Herr Oberarzt.
Schwanoma?
Bitte?
Schwanoma kann sein, Sie haben recht.
Und möchten Sie in diesem Fall Hörtest?
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig.
Hörtest ist eine wichtige Symptome bei dieser Erkrankung.
Wir sollen einen Hörtest durchführen, Sie haben recht.
Ist es wichtig, in diesem Fall eine KG-Schreibung und eine Eschokardiographie durchzuführen?
Der Patient leidet unter vertigo.
Herzdichtungsstörungen können diese Symptome verursachen.
Deswegen sollen wir eine EKG-Schreibung und eine Eschokardiographie durchführen.
Sie haben recht.
Und als Differentialdiagnose denken Sie Serumen?
Serumen? Was meinen Sie damit, Herr Oberarzt?
Außer Hörgang gibt es Serumen.
Bei der Untersuchung sollen wir Hörgang genau untersuchen, ob es ein Problem da gibt.
Meinen Sie, in diesem Fall werden Sie eine Autoskopie durchführen?
Ja, Autoskopie.
Können Sie uns Autoskopie aufklären?
Autoskopie. Das ist eine gute Frage, Herr Oberarzt.
Ok, zuerst. Autoskopie ist eine Untersuchungmethode für Hörgang, für Hörgänge.
Diese Untersuchungmethode hilft mir, die Verletzungen, Fremddinge und Entzündungen und andere Veränderungen der Hörgänge genau zu erkennen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung sieht der Patient einfach und machen wir diese Untersuchung mit einem speziellen Gerät.
Das ist eine Autoskopie.
Wir führen die Autoskopie in den Hörgang ein und dann gucken wir durch die Autoskopie in die Hörgänge,
wenn es ein Fremddinge in der Hörgänge oder in der Hörgänge gibt,
können wir diese Dinge mit einem Gerät ausnehmen und wir können auch die Probleme mit Timpanischen genau feststellen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung dauert einige Minuten und dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen für diese Untersuchung.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Einschränkungen und der Patient kann seinen Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Machen Sie in diesem Fall einen Stimmgabel-Test?
Stimmgabel-Test können wir machen. Wir werden die Hörstörungen genau beurteilen.
Deswegen sollen wir einen Stimmgabel-Test durchführen. Sie haben recht.
Können Sie uns die Stimmgabel-Untersuchung aufklären?
Bei dieser Untersuchung benutzen wir ein spezielles Gerät. Das ist wie ein Gabel.
Zuerst vibriertieren wir diese Gabel und legen wir dieses Gerät neben dem Ohr.
Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert bei mir. Herr Oberst, ich habe nur Grundkenntnisse mit diesem Thema. Es tut mir leid.
Was empfehlen Sie den Patienten nach der Akutbehandlung?
Wenn es eine Entzündungssituation gibt, eine Infektion, sollen wir eine Antibiotika verschreiben.
Der Patient muss viel trinken, ruhig stehen, besonders in einem dunklen Raum, beruhigen und von stressigen Situationen vermeiden.
Ich habe eine Frage. Was sind die Ursachen bei der Morbus Meniere?
Es gibt zentrale und peripherale Ursachen bei dieser Erkrankung.
Es kann auch Infektionen sein.
Ist Morbus Meniere eine Autohymin-Krise oder ist es eine Tumoridinfektion?